Ali beyond
[Music]
look like everyone's got a different
name for it they're all bound for the
same destination doesn't matter what you
call it I know we're going to find that
and I'm frying foolish I have to show me
hey everybody it's Charlie have you ever
seen anything so full of splendor this
is gonna be my West world episode 2
video obviously spoiler warning if you
haven't seen the episode yet if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe I'm doing Westworld
all season long but we learned about
Williams greatest mistake we had a
reunion the episode was titled reunion
we had reunions with a number of
characters we haven't seen since season
1 most notably young William and Logan
we actually saw a bunch of different
time lines - there was 30 years ago
before delos invested in the company
then there was a little bit after the
events of season 1 then there's the two
weeks ago timeline when they're still
starting the beginning of the revolt so
we'll just try to remind everyone where
we are in the time line as we were
through top 10 WTF and the secret of
Williams greatest mistake but number 10
we get our first have you ever seen
anything so full of splendor from
probably one of the youngest versions of
Dolores that we've seen so far this is
from well before Arnold son Charlie had
died this is before dell o--'s had
invested in the company which we learned
is called the argos initiative that's
the name of the start-up that Ford and
Arnold called their company when they
first started building the parks but
they were bleeding money so they needed
outside investors so that's where Delos
comes in but because of this big influx
of cash they're now really rich people
so that's why Arnold is saying wife has
been very good to me I have all this
money I'm building this house I'm moving
my family here so Dolores extracts the
promise from him promise that you'll
bring me back here and he's like oh yeah
of course I'll bring you back here kind
of making you wonder if we're gonna end
the season on a moment like this in
present day with the current version of
Dolores making it out of the park back
to this location and saying have you
ever seen anything so full of splendor
again bringing that line back around so
just remember how lines of dialogue
recur there were at least three
different times in the episode where
different people or different versions
of people said have you ever seen
anything so full of splendor including
different versions of Dolores and
different versions of the man in black
or William young William I should say
but number 9 back in present day Dolores
wakes Teddy up he gets super woke it's
like showing someone their entire
browser history like oh you thought that
we cleared this no this is everything
that's happened to you
why would you do this to me he starts
freaking out my favorite thing about
this scene too is the look on Delores
his face while she's watching this
happen like she's just completely casual
about it like okay we're just gonna let
Teddy do his thing here freak out a
little bit but just remember that most
of what happened in present day on the
show this week was from that two weeks
ago timeline so like when I say two
weeks ago Delores I'm talking about
Delores and present-day right after the
start of the revolt so just remember
that there are two different timelines
in present day there's stuff that
happens at the very end of the season
which is when Bernhard is standing on
the shore oh my god I killed them all
that's two weeks into the future two
weeks into the past is right here where
the revolt starts dolor starts going
around recruiting people like the
Confederate OHS so it'll get a little
crazy but I think within each episode
they try to limit it to at least three
different timelines the number 8 Logan's
special presentation we get to see young
William and Logan before the events of
season 1 so this is happening right
after we saw Arnold with this version of
Dolores this is almost the furthest back
we've gone in the past I think the
earliest time point we've seen on the TV
show is when Dolores is still all
skeleton looking getting off the table
because remember Dolores is the very
first host that they ever built she's
the prototype for everything that came
after which is why she's so important
she says she's seen everything she's
been around for all of this so the whole
deal here is they're just trying to get
the del O's company to invest in the
park the argos initiative and you
basically see the party where everybody
is a host I loved the reveal like just
seeing Logan completely freaked out but
the minute that Angela walked in with
this new character who's also part of
the ghost nation storyline will meet
more of him later this season but he's a
pretty important character when she
first walked in with him I knew
immediately that this was going to be
some big twist where they're gonna play
a joke on him but the funny thing here
is the way they transition you even see
Clementine playing the piano so there
are actually a lot of characters from
present-day that recur in this party
scene like the lead Confederate O
character the Dolores is talking to in
present day is this character right here
during the flashbacks angela is the
funniest because she's sort of like this
Jesus figure with the crown of thorns on
her head but she seems kind of like a
zombie just
Bing divorces every wish just mowing
people down whatever she tells them but
in the past it seems like she almost has
more agency so it'll be interesting to
see what's going on with Angela and
present day if she's just like this
Terminator bought that Dolores controls
but also I almost forgot there's the
surprise Anthony Hopkins cameo
voice-over only so it's kind of out of
focus and it's in the background but
it's new dialogue he recorded for the
young version of Ford and even though it
was Gus fring doing Ford later in the
episode in the town of pariah that was
actually a really cool twist this just
reminds you that we're gonna be seeing
Ford throughout this season through
these other hosts as he sort of pushes
William along you're meant to play this
game alone William so that even though
Ford might be dead he's speaking in
guiding things from beyond the grave so
it'll be interesting to see where else
Ford pops up this season so he's still a
character on the show even though
Anthony Hopkins himself is not
physically on the show anymore very cool
but number seven dead isn't what it used
to be Lawrence so we have our reunion
between Lawrence and the man in black
the whole intro scene is just about the
different power dynamic between those
two characters previously the man in
black had total control over everything
in their relationship but now it's a
little more equal like he needs
Lawrence's help to save himself so think
about all the abuse that the man in
black visited on Lawrence last season he
hung him up drained him then used that
fluid to patch up Teddy so the Teddy
could take him the rest of the way when
he was still trying to find the maze
it's sort of a twist on the change in
the power dynamic in the relationship
between Maeve and Sizemore this season
where as like it used to be Sizemore in
control of everything
now Maeve is the one in control in
Sizemore is sort of just pushed around
by her will but number six probably one
of the coolest new scenes that we've got
with the new character we finally meet
James Delos and young William after the
events of season 1 explains to him why
the park is a value to the company and
it has absolutely nothing to do with the
broadening of the human experience or
developing AI it's all about data mining
and just using user data within the park
that they collect to better market
products in the real world to these
people so like young William tells him
you know people in here are
honest about the choices that they make
that gives us better data about what
they really want
so the delos company has a much easier
time selling people the right goods
meaning that they make much more money
on all the other business that they do
just a big tech company collecting user
data then turning that around selling it
to companies so that they can better
market products to their users based on
the choices that they make when they're
in the park or say on their website in
the case of Facebook let me know if
anybody else thought that when he talked
about using the park for data mining and
marketing purposes they just screamed
Facebook to me just because there's been
all this Facebook privacy and security
issues going on lately I love the James
Della's character too he talks about how
he doesn't care about the future I'm not
gonna be here in 20 years so I'll talk
about that in a second too because there
was another scene later where he talks
about a plan that's not quite ready yet
the whole idea being that these
corporate people are very short-sighted
they only care about short-term profits
they're not thinking about the evolution
of the human race how the hosts might
become the new dominant life-form on the
planet
Logan had a scene later too that sort of
tipped me off on that like that's
probably what he's talking about when he
says that they lit the match themselves
we'll get to that in a second but number
5 dolorous vs. Maeve
I love the standoff that they have here
because they're the two most powerful
hosts in the park right now mostly
because Maeve is the most self-aware and
has been enhanced the most remember
she's one of the only hosts that has had
the little technology that they used to
keep them in the parks removed there's
like a fail-safe that all the hosts have
that won't allow them to leave or will
self-destruct them if they try to leave
this white last season she had her body
burned so that when they rebuilt her
they could rebuild her without that
specific failsafe device but this is
just to let you know that Maeve is gonna
be on a separate path a completely
separate storyline although I'm
expecting everyone to converge at this
special place that they tease at the end
of the episode the place that William
regrets the most number four Delores in
the Confederate owes this was great this
is her just trying to win the army that
she needs to fight those 800 people that
they teased earlier in the episode so
you immediately realized the value of
her keeping that tech alive with them so
that he can resurrect the host on will
so she just proves to them
what the truth is like the same thing
that Teddy got only she has to kill them
first for them to be able to believe it
just because they're programmed to be
like that the retirement party
this is actually a really important idea
this is the point at which William takes
control as CEO the Dell O's corporation
we find that he has a little daughter so
this is further after the events of
season 1 Dolores comes back he actually
flips a little bit I love the look on
his face when he sees her them he's like
oh my secret girlfriend is getting
ready to meet my family this is gonna be
awkward his wife actually also seems
really cold towards him remember we
learned that in the future his wife ends
up killing herself because she can't
stand living with the man in black she's
so afraid of him there are a couple of
teases that they give here to james
Delos says that he's stepping down and
not necessarily by choice as if the
board asked him to step down he implies
that he's sick maybe it has something to
do with him dying William says that the
plan isn't quite ready yet but he
doesn't look that old so it just sounds
like he has a degenerative condition
that they're using the technology of the
park to try and fix and that has
something to do with this special data
facility that they're all going towards
the weapon that Doris is talking about
but we also get to check in with Logan
who's just getting super high by himself
out in the dark remember this is Logan
after the events of season 1 so he's
lost whatever a personal battle he's had
with William so Logan's left to rot off
in the distance but he tells Dolores
that the whole human race is starting to
burn in Delos lit the match it probably
has something to do with them backing
the part in the host becoming the
dominant life-form like it's all
building towards this revolt that's
happening in present day but Dolores
also has that line of dialogue again
have you ever seen anything so full of
splendor but then number 3 back in
present-day the two weeks ago timeline
we have man in black versus Ford from
beyond the grave
through Gus fring from Breaking Bad in
the town of pariah this is so fun it
gets super meta too because he's like
Lawrence you used to be this character
30 years ago
Eliz Oh and he gives him that big long
speech about the elephants that doesn't
want to fight back because it learned at
a young age that it shouldn't resist it
is all tied up in the idea that Dolores
keeps saying that not everyone is
destined for this promised land the
valley beyond that there
end point for the season so there are
hosts within the park that don't want to
fight their programming so it sounds
like Dolores is weeding those out that's
who Gus fring is he's one of those
people that doesn't want to fight and
then you get that awesome twist where
Ford from beyond the grave speaks
through these characters and makes them
all shoot themselves so that William
can't use them but number two bigger
reveal man and black reveals that he
built this place and we're going towards
his greatest mistake and he refers to it
as a place but then we get the twist
later where Dolores talks about it as a
weapon you get a flashback scene after
the retirement party with young William
and Dolores where he sort of explains
what his grand plan is takes Dolores to
see this special place that we're all
going towards at the end of the season
and says have you ever seen anything so
full of splendor but there's sort of a
sinister twist to it so if you're
wondering what's going on here it sounds
like this has something to do with the
data mining that they were talking about
earlier in the episode so remember
there's a secret reason why Delos cares
about the park and it's mostly sold on
the idea of data mining Dolores says
that she's going to use it as a weapon
against the humans and it sounds like
she's saying that she's gonna use their
browser history against them remember
this all goes back into data mining and
marketing like really insidious stuff
and it's not like future world where
they're literally replacing people from
the real world
it's literally holding people hostage to
their data now there might be something
bigger going on here because you have
this side plot going on with James Delos
who seems like he might want to somehow
cheat death using the technology of the
park so there might be some grander
stuff going on but we have seen a couple
scenes in this red room with a bunch of
what looks like data processors and just
really crazy stuff going on it might
have something to do with that but just
let me know in the comments below what
do you think this special place that
William took Dolores is that Dolores and
present-day says is a weapon she's going
to use against people what will happen
is is I'll post my trailer video in the
morning there'll be a bunch more Marvel
infinity war stuff happening - but click
here for all my infinity war Easter eggs
and click here for my episode 1 video
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you
tonight